J'étais comme toi vulnérable
incertain effrayé par la mort il y a
seulement 12 heures IMAX c'est comme dire
au conducteur veux-tu conduire une Ferrari
je veux être sûr que je l'utilise au
bon endroit au bon moment
Lucy est tout le monde  c'est une
étudiante de 25 ans elle est à Taipei elle se demande
ce qu'elle va faire de sa vie elle est
un peu perdue en fait et tombe ou son
labo cette situation ou elle
pourra atteindre la partie paternelle de son
cerveau on dit que nous les humains  utiliser seulement
10% de notre capacité cérébrale mais mais
il y avait un moyen d'accéder à 100% de notre
cerveau c'est un voyage incroyable pour cette
fille et pour nous aussi parce que nous l'aimons
bien pourrait m'arriver ou vous le temps d'y
aller nous avons travaillé  en neuf micros et
on sent vraiment la différence à
la fin mademoiselle elle a des capacités
surtout dans les 15 dernières minutes du
film où tu sors vraiment de l'espace
et ça t'a été très utile les gens
qui auront la chance de voir sur IMAX
nous avons un plein  l'expérience du film
et il sera probablement encore plus sous le
choc à la fin
vous